hello everyone in this video I will talk
about interference in details in my
earlier video I have described
interference in Keenan short and concise
manner but in this video I would in
details described the discovery of
interference subdivision of interferon
classes interferon signalling and also
the medical usage of interference now as
a name suggests interfere interferon
means to interfere with something and we
would look at what it is interfering if
we go back to 1950 s then you see eg new
novel and dr. Kojima who are Japanese
biologists were trying to develop a
vaccine for smallpox they were using
rabbit skin and testes tissue to get the
cell cultures so they are culturing
rabbit skin and tasty samples in the
cultured sample when they inject the
small the small pox of the cowpox virus
the cells are getting affected but they
did a several different trick in which
they injected a cell with a UV
attenuated cowpox virus and they saw
once they and after that once they
infected the cell line again with a
normal virus which is not heat
attenuated then we saw the infection
that was produced was not spreading
throughout the cells so the inspection
was very local later in vivo experiment
in rabbits also suggest that when
rabbits were immunized with a cow pox
virus on the skin so first the infection
spread but if they are injected with a
heat killed or UV attenuated virus then
the infection doesn't spread that much
wine once it is what while it is
affected for the second time the
infection doesn't spread that much that
means in response to that UV attenuated
or heat killed virus
there is something produced inside the
body of this rabbit that is kind of a so
called viral inhibitory factor that is
preventing the viral infection to spread
while the when the organism is infected
for the second time so what was this
viral infinitely factor so these two
scientists with serial experiments has
shown that the nature of this viral
inhibitory factor was clearly not
antibody but most of the research paper
were either in Japanese or in French so
this kind of excitement in the field was
suppressed for a long time then another
group of scientists Alec Isaac and dr.
Linda men were growing influenza viruses
in chicken egg and in the chicken egg
there is Korea al-alam TOEIC membrane
where people normally inject the virus
to grow them and this kind of technique
is still used till date to culture
viruses so they were injecting viruses
into that but when they inject the Korea
Aetna and lung TOEIC membrane with a UV
attenuated viruses they have seen the
virus doesn't grow that much at all when
it came injected with the normal virus
so that means something is produced in
response to a UV attenuated virus and
that is checking the growth of not
normal growth of virus and since we are
interfering with the growth process of
virus they named this as interference
from that time it was known as
interference
now interference were produced at very
local low amount and the work in very
low concentration has well so the
problem was since not much amount of
interferon was could be extracted so the
structural details on how the function
it was not totally no because there was
two less amount in 1978 when biochemical
methods grows and by little there was an
advancement in biochemical methods then
x-ray crystallographic structure of
interferon-gamma
could be revealed and that revealed a
lot of structural and functional details
and shed a lot of light about how
interferon functions now interference
are one of the family member of the six
cytokine families so interferon family
is subdivided into three sub families
interferon class 1 class 2 and class 3
interferon interferon class 1 consists
mainly interferon alpha alpha beta
whereas class 2 interferons comprised of
interferon gamma and interleukin 10
whereas in newly discovered interferon
lambda which is discovered in 2003 is
the prevalent family member of
interferon class 3 subfamily now
interferon alpha and beta are secreted
by dendritic cell or macrophages in
response to pathogen invasion let's say
here is a pathogen invasion and the
dendritic cell which are like patrolling
police officers send out a alarming
signal this alarming signal here is
interferon alpha or interferon beta as
if the dendritic cell is asking for
backup towards its fellow mate just like
this police officer is asking for a
backup so dendritic cell secret a lot of
these interference around and this
attracts more dendritic cells or
macrophages near the site of action so
that would help the immune system to
boost its response also interferon alpha
and interferon beta is the formation of
bias the differentiation of the T cell
towards R th one fight and th one
helpers
th 1 4 th 1 C d-four temper cells are
mostly well known for their inflammatory
roles and thereby they they do a lot of
inflammatory so they also synthesize
many inflammatory mediators now
interferon class 2 family member that
means interferon gamma has a huge
antiviral role and we would discuss
about it let's say this yellow cell is
infected by a virus
now what after after infection what
would happen the virus would give its
internal genetic material whether RNA or
DNA inside the host cell and using the
host cell protein machinery it would
produce a viral proteins now viral
proteins would be normally degraded by
the degradation machinery of the cell
which is proteasome and the viral
proteins some of the viral proteins
would be loaded onto the class 1 MHC in
the ER after that it would be displayed
on the cells surface once it is
displayed on the cell surface they are
patrolling cd8 positive cytotoxic killer
cells which are like specialized killers
so they would recognize the final
peptide on class 1 MHC and they would
kind of engage with that cell and
secrete a lot of transients and
porphyrins
and ultimately secreted grams i'm and
porphyrin would induce apoptosis in that
targeted cell now the targeted cell is
dead but its role is not over the
targeted cell produced something which
is actually interferon gamma and that
binds to nearby cell it works like an
alarming signal for their neighbors so
the interferon secreted by the dead cell
the cell which was about to die points
to the interferon receptor on the nearby
cell and in give rise to specific signal
which ultimately produce antiviral
mechanisms which can combat virus
infection
now these interferon receptors are
basically tyrosine kinase receptors so
these are bound to Janus kinase or Chex
so once interferon bind to it Jack gives
phosphorylated also it phosphorylates
that may in this example this green
interferon is me if the green different
signaling is mediated by step 1 and step
2 phosphorylated step 1 and step 2
dimerize and the dimerize step 1 and
step 2 step means signal transduction
and transcription so step 1 migrates to
the nucleus and binds to specific
binding region where it would give rise
to a specific set of genes here the
yellow interferon which is a different
interferon give rise to interferon
signalling but might use different
combination of stats and then give rise
to several other genes which are
transfused this is how the uniqueness of
the signaling could be maintained now
the common targets that the stat is
giving rise we would look at it but stat
could give rise to first proliferative
molecules like PCL - like see me climb
cyclin D etc also here is a list given
then what combination of jacks and what
combination of stats are used by several
cytokine and cytokine receptors now the
cytokine signaling the interferon
signalling give rise to specific
antiviral proteins we would look at look
at them one is protein kinase our
protein kinase R would sequester viral
RNA and kind of interfere with the
process of the Eric Idle assembly now
that means also it is inhibiting the
viral translation translation of the
viral TS RNA also PKR
is a kindness with
phosphorylate initiation factor to alpha
which indirectly inhibition inhibit the
translation also interferon signalling
can produce two five illegal air filters
the to five all us think is can bind to
specific viral genetic material and it
can allow it market for destruction by
RNAs in family proteins another
important molecule that is produced by
interferon signalling is MX protein MX
protein polymerize and also inhibit
viral assembly so these are few strategy
used by the downstream signaling of
interferon and this is how a neighboring
cell which is not virally infected it's
preparing himself for the viral or
combat when once it gives the alarming
signal from its neighbor now interferon
has certain medical usage as well
interferon is used to treat sudden viral
diseases like hepatitis C special
specifically interferon alpha is used
for this treatment autoimmune disease
such as rheumatoid arthritis could be
treated using interferon therapy also
multiple sclerosis could be treated by
interferon beta other cases of several
cancers and several variety of myeloma
and some renowned cell carcinoma could
be treated by interference so that kind
of concludes my video on interferon if
you liked my video give it a big thumbs
up don't forget to subscribe and share
this video with your friends and thank
you